avocat d'affaires le jour et bonnes
affaires la nuit voici guillaume faber
interview vérité
or guillaume faber bonsoir c'est bien
sûr pas ton roi non non non c'est pas
vraiment sont a demandé de porter un
masque ce soir c'est parce que d'abord
publié un bouquin chez régine de forges
qui s'appelle autoportrait en direction
on va en parler et puis c'est ensuite
parce que tu as peur que tu es que tes
clients sachent que tu écris ce genre de
bouquin
[Musique]
et il ya aussi le fait que dans ce livre
je parle de femmes de dix ans d'enquêté
amoureux et je voudrais pas qu'on puisse
les reconnaître non plus enfin des
canidés brigitte y en a pas mal quand
même
oui mais enfin je donne à céder certains
détails qui pourraient permettre à leurs
proches de les identifier donc je serai
à mon avis discourtois de mai lorsque tu
dis pour commencer le bouquin c'est que
ce qui est important dans cette
dans cette autobiographie en fait c'est
que avant tout celle autobiographique ta
verges
absolument mais elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas extraordinaire en plus elle
mesure 17 cm et une longueur tudyk est
somme toute assez banal oui d'après ce
que je sais c'est dans la bonne moyenne
mais prêt elle fait 3 cm de diamètre ça
c'est pas terrible je sais pas là
thierry fait mieux mais j'ai pas tu dis
qu'on ne fait rarement des compliments
quand il ya une fois une fille qui tu as
dit que tu avais une belle que m'enfin
c'est pas non plus ouais je sais pas ça
ce sera après demain va d'ailleurs pour
le compliment est dit ça parce que tu
les payes à vous faites eu droit à non
pas du tout non c'était parce qu'on
avait passé un bon moment ensemble et
c'était peut-être la reconnaissance du
ventre comme on dit là tu dis qu'elle
est fonctionnel oui qu'elle s'adapte à
tout type 2
de vagins d'anus de bouche qui est pas
mal finalement les assez passe partout
c'est alors par contre est beaucoup
moins gentil pour le sexe féminin tu
parles de boursouflures tu parles de
deux formes vague tu dis que c'est que
cet effet par un chirurgien malade et
vieillissant
ça vient d'où cette espèce de désamour
pour le sexe féminin on va je pense que
ça vient de ma culture moi j'ai été
élevé dans le culte de la statuaire
grecque par exemple toutes les formes
sont lisses praxitèle je lis nra et il
est évident que le sexe féminin à côté
attirant son plan sexuel mais quand
esthétique il a rien d'extraordinaire
ouais pas que ce serait d'ailleurs sur
les statuts ya un truc qui te fait pas
trop marrer non plus et le baiser je
veux dire à part dans ton jeune âge
maintenant tu dis la bouche des femmes
c'est pour ma verges
le baiser en fait c'est un substitut à
la ours blancs c'est quand on peut pas
faire autrement tu dis qu'on fait des
langues des langues fourré dans de
profondes tranchées dans un ascenseur et
qu'on peut pas baiser quoi oui ce soir
mais d'ailleurs je crois que je suis
assez mauvais au niveau baiser donc
d'abord oui c'est un bon [ __ ] mettez
pas la star du grand besoin j'en sais
rien mais j'ai quand même tu parles de
ton dépucelage étudie que ce jour là
avec cette chaire les lis tu me dis
quand même leslie oui tu dit que c'était
quand même six fois de suite ce n'est
pas un peu prétentieux celle ci tout de
suite non mais ça c'est parce que
j'avais 50 bouteilles et donc la
pression
ouais c'est une bonne performance je
crois en vieillissante un peu plus
modeste quand même pas oui maintenant
honnêtement oui je viens du starter et
c'est quand on a un coût pour retarder
l'éjaculation qui est pas mal et
érigeant qu'emploie des crèmes des
machins des trucs toi c'est pas mal tu
pense à tes factures
je pense à tes factures qui s'accumulent
sur ton bureau ça marche ouais ça marche
enfin souvent c'est pas très fort après
il ya tout un tout un chapitre sur les
sur les positions en missionnaire par
exemple en le missionnaire
c'est le début quoi on il faut en passer
par là mais enfin c'est vrai que sur le
plan fonctionnel c'est pas du tout
agréable en fin de mois je suis assez
lourd en plus donc aux gars je me
soutient sur les coudes et commence à
fatiguer alors j'ai craqué sur les draps
rugueuse en plus souvent très malin dans
tout le corps d'une femme est à mon avis
une jolie
dans le producteur allemand était devenu
un amoureux du dos un adepte de la
levrette parce que je suis pas le seul
où vous croyez pouvoir parle entre nous
on dit peut-être pas toujours mais c'est
vrai d'ailleurs que la position
naturelle au physiologiste pression je
prends comme une bête mais oui mais on
est bien content aussi
quand on fait l'amour en fait taper
qualité une belle expression c'est la
paresseuse chose un joli mois ouais je
sais pas moi qui l'inventé je les
trouvais dans un bouquin libertin jours
il faut que le correspond tout à fait à
cantonner sur le côté oui ce soir on
peut même presque sans dormir si c'est
paris c'est une façon de s'endormir en
dix ans dans ce bâtiment l'amazone t'es
pas fanatique
ensuite quand c'est vraiment fatigué oui
il ya en même temps que je prends une
femme trop forte
la masturbation par contre tu dis c'est
la panacée universelle explique nous
comment faire une bonne masturbation
imagine que les gens de leur garçon dans
leur lit
or je pense que chacun trouve l'intérêt
pendant dix minutes après l'émission qui
et comment ils s'y prennent
et je pense que chacun a sa manière de
se masturber disons si réalisé la
plupart des gens refusent de reconnaître
qui se masturbe mon frère quand on en
parle un peu avec eux aussi des reason
que les femmes d'ailleurs ils
reconnaissent qu'ils le font ils ont un
peu honte alors pour avoir des détails
c'est difficile pour moi je connais une
jeune fille par exemple qui se masturber
dans sa douche avec le pommeau de la
douche
mais oui aragon la pression etc il
semblait assez raffiné d'ailleurs mais
elle osait dire à personne
donc chacun a sa technique je prends non
c'est pas comme la fellation ça tout ça
la fellation pas un grand adepte pas ce
que tu dis que finalement la bouche de
la femme c'est le meilleur réceptacle
pour la verge de l'homme
non mais je suis pas je parle de tous
les hommes sont comme moi face à
l'extérieur trouve que tous les hommes
qui sont morts en vain l'amour sont tous
morts en se faisant faire une fellation
ah bon les hommes célèbres les annales
certains cardinal dont on pense que et
ses jours parce qu'avec la fondation
sais pas pourquoi le 40 à 140 et c est
alors film j'en ai un peu usé va au
clash
ouais la sodomie dans la sodomie tu dis
que c'est comme christophe colomb quand
il a découvert l'amérique de tulle a
découvert par hasard
m genre tu t'es trompé quoi j'ai glissé
ouais c'est vrai ça ah oui il ya plus
m'en vais d'ailleurs ma partenaire sur
les personnes cinq mois après plus tard
hélas rien dit oh non non produit tout à
la fois du temps de le lire ce que tu
dis ça tu dis qu'au début les femmes
sont réticentes enfin dans tes
expériences puis que finalement elles
sont toutes d'accord bout d'un moment
oui à condition qu'on ne considère pas
la sodomie comme une façon de châtier ou
d'être ça dit qu'il faudrait c'est un
acte d'amour c'est pas le pouvoir quand
on évoque un libertin la sodomie c'est
une façon de finir une femme est alors
évidemment ça peut être mal est une
punition
enfin moi j'ai jamais forcer personne
n'a quoi que ce soit et la sodomie c'est
un plaisir partagé même bien savoir la
wii j'aime beaucoup
pourquoi parce que le rectum à une forme
pas comme le vagin il ya des choses plus
bon bah je l'expliqué il ya une part moi
j'aurais dit oui mais j'aurais actuelle
explique aux gens qu'il aura à mon avis
mécaniquement c'est parce que la
friction sur le verger - exemple
puisqu'il ya juste le
la rampe au sens la rampe il ya juste
dix ans le l'entré deux
nous quand ils rentrent leurs achats
fois on est dans un grand vide ouais
donc on prend beaucoup de temps à dire
ce que c'est ça la question
on est là mais tenez vous prêtes à
facebook 1 pour apprendre aux gens pour
faire partager aux genton citant côté
pédagogue comme quand tu vas donner des
cours dans les écoles où c'est pour
faire du plein de points non pas du tout
j'ai écrit ce livre par plaisir
personnel pour un petit peu faire le
point sur mes façons de faire l'amour et
non pas seulement sur mes sentiments
fait jour je me suis dit dans le fond
les sentiments c'est beau mais n'y a pas
que ça et le reste on n'entend jamais
non que j'ai essayé de faire un petit
point
un bilan quelque sorte ce bouquin j'ai
mis trois ans quatre ans à l'écrire je
n'ai pas eu une seule traite
mais justement tu l'a écrit par petits
pas petit paragraphe a écrit quand le
soir en rentrant chez toi le temps
d'apaiser tiens je vais faire un petit
chapiteau à wenzhou
mais quand il y avait un truc qui me
venait à l'esprit tu as pris du plaisir
à l'écrire a beaucoup de plaisir oui ça
t'a fait bander l'écrire solide bah oui
certaines fortes parce qu'il a des
souvenirs et arrêté pour s'être masturbé
rare oui mais parfois les clous on est
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu